so we got a bunch of republicans this is
this is interesting here's a story from
the hill house gop stages mass mandate
protest nearly 40 maskless house
republican lawmakers walked across the
capitol on the senate floor to protest
of the capital physician's decision to
reinstate a masked mandate in the lower
chamber but not in the upper chamber how
does that make sense
republicans complained the policy backed
by pelosi and other democrats is
inconsistent infringes on personal
liberty and is based on politics not
science however the body of the 100
member senate is less than a quarter of
the size of the 435 member house and all
about a handful of senators are
vaccinated while dozens of house
republicans have refused to say whether
they got the vaccine okay
i heard bill de blasio
he said either you get the vaccine or
you get a negative covet test
okay but people who are vaccinated can
still transmit right covet so
what's the purpose for having
non-vaccinated people get tested it
certainly could not be to prevent
sick people from coming to work because
the interesting thing about this
is that if you are not vaccinated you're
likely to have a more severe reaction
they say you're more likely to be
hospitalized okay stands to reason you
are more likely to actually show
symptoms in which case you know you're
sick you'll stay home
the vaccinated people are less likely to
be symptomatic or to go to hospitals or
to die it's a good reason to get the
vaccine to be honest but again talk to
your doctor and anyway the point is
why then are they not requiring tests
for the vaccinated
we can tell better if unvaccinated
people are sick not vaccinated people so
this this policy of having people get
vaccinated and then claiming that's the
reason why you know some people don't
have to wear masks makes literally no
sense you can still transmit with or
without that's actually the argument for
why they want the masks in which case
the senate should have to wear masks too
and negative tests are meaningless
nothing makes sense none of it makes
sense no but also the whole thing with
testing like what if you caught covet on
the way over to work like would it
wouldn't even show up in the test yet
right you'd get a negative test you'd be
oh i'm i don't have covet you'd walk
around you'd breathe on everybody and
then you know
what would be the point of it are they
test does a test test for antibody
response no i think that's a blood test
yeah that's the specific antibody test i
think the general pcr tests are like
they swab right uh yeah and then they
put it and then the pcr thing multiplies
the genetic material and that makes it
easier for him to spot specific things
i i don't
there's been no logical reason i mean
look i've had a lot of conversations
with people about all of this stuff and
i'm like dude i want to believe that
we're all going to come together and
we're going to change the world and save
everything and you know uh
we all we all pitch in 15 days slow
spread all that stuff you just got to
tell me what to do and why we're doing
it yeah that's all i'm asking and
they're like you got to wear them as
like okay why and they're like
i mean slow the spread and i was like
sure how but i heard them say we don't
have to wear masks anymore like
vaccinated well now vaccinated people
need to wear masks and like you said
what changed mm-hmm all right what and i
had one guy say to me dude it's op the
science says that we have to do you know
everybody who can't get vaccinated [ __ ]
and i was like
okay
what science
and then he's just like huh
i'm like dude i'm
i'm not gonna sit here and have someone
for political reasons tell me take
medication i just
i need i i'm i'm begging you i am
begging the media and the democrats to
just answer the questions and i know
there's probably a lot of good answers
out there and this is what brings me to
the ultimate problem
i'm sure right now there's a democrat
out there a lefty who hates me and
thinks my show is bad saying like the
answer's all right here you don't even
got to think about it the cdc just says
it and i'm like bro the cdc said
something yesterday and changed it
tomorrow and i'll change it tomorrow
fauci they they just revised their their
math guidelines proving they were
actually wrong about masks in the first
place i'm confused man
yeah and the mask didn't slow the spread
how about that like how about we never
talk about the fact that the places that
masked really heavily still had the
highest concentration of deaths and tons
of cases and it turns out the covet is a
seasonal virus and there's very little
we can do about it and we have to just
move on what if we just moved on
there's a vaccine there's several
there's a new one coming out soon oh wow
people have a choice to get it and if
they do they're safe
so what's the issue
no like serious question i'm not trying
to be a dick i'm just like genuinely
asking the issue is the vaccines were
rushed out you know they're still
they're still experimental that's a big
part of the issue well i i i
think they're they're approved for
emergency use
i suppose uh
my understanding is there are a lot of
stories they've been they've been
through clinical trials uh i think it's
uh it's it was it was fast it was
operation warp speed that's true
but i think you know there's there's two
reasons we're seeing a lot of the verse
adverse reactions
one is that we just did like 360 or
whatever 336 million doses so you're
going to see a much higher not everybody
gets the flu shot you know what i mean
so you have a huge pool of individuals
you're going to see those percentages
and they and they've never said that
wasn't the case they've always said
there's there's adverse reactions but i
think the other issue is that
when uh so stakehomes we mentioned
stakeholders right
stakehomes posted
uh about
the vaccine and trusting the experts and
like how we have to learn our
limitations and talk to our doctors and
i was like
sacoms love you bro but when i said
talk to your doctor i got attacked for
it i had people calling me an
anti-vaxxer and saying it's a waste of
time the doctor will say get it you're
you're making people scared and i'm like
i think one of the reasons we have so
many bears reports is because there are
people who don't go to their doctors and
just show up to one of these like
outside of 7-eleven and sit down and
hey give me the vaccine and if they went
to their doctor the doctor could have
said like oh i noticed your history as
an ex like maybe you should consider
waiting just a little bit maybe they
still would have recommended it and
there are some people that probably
wouldn't have been recommended it and
then we can reduce the adverse erection
and reduce the hesitancy for people who
might be scared because they're seeing a
bunch of stuff in the news yeah on the
flip side of that i think if the doctors
had the vaccines at this point i think
more people would get them from their
doctor not from outside of 7-eleven i
think for a lot of people it's like i
don't want to go to yankee stadium and
get a shot i want to get it from my
doctor and until my doctor has it i
don't feel like this is a real thing
that that's a really good point uh
there was a story on hannity
so hannity comes out and he's like
everybody i take the vaccine science
very seriously you know you should
consider it or whatever there were a lot
of trump supporters who are posting
things saying like you know f hannity
you know whatever mom like trump trump
supported this like trump was a favorite
but that's a really good point the guy
who this guy calls uh hannity to talk
about what happened with his doctor and
media matters ends up writing about it
negatively and then a bunch of people on
the left started saying you know oh
hannity's reversal was short-lived there
was no reversal the republicans have
always supported the vaccine right
desantis has always been going around
doing this but here's what happened in
that story the guy said i'm a cancer
survivor the cdc actually says on their
website talk to your doctor before
getting these vaccines if you're a
cancer survivor and so he went to his
doctor and he said he was immuno you
know the doctor says look you're
immunocompromised i would recommend
getting this vaccine because you want to
protect yourself you know your
immunocompromised and the man said i
then asked my doctor if you would
prescribe it for that reason and
administer it and his doctor said no
what
i don't know and i was like
well online they say you don't need a
prescription for it but you know what
i've gotten prescriptions for ibuprofen
i've gone to the doctor and they're like
i'm prescribing ibuprofen go pick it up
and so this guy said until my doctor
will prescribe it to me as something i
need because i'm a cancer survivor and
until he will administer it i don't want
to take the risk because i'm worried
about the the underlying health
conditions i have and i'm like
he's scared this is a guy who's who's
legitimately worried about his health
and people are yelling at him he's an
anti-vaxxer they're insulting and i'm
like dude that's got to be a scary
position to be in the cdc says warning
for cancer survivors talk to your doctor
your doctor says i'm not going to
prescribe it or administer it not even
administer it doc can't you no right i'd
be like dude i'm worried because i don't
know who this guy is you're telling me
to go to someone else to get it but you
won't do it
that i'd be scared too and every
politician who wants restaurants or bars
to ask people their vaccine status when
that guy comes to the door and he's like
well i don't have i didn't get the
vaccine because i'm a can he has to
explain it to a bouncer who has to then
make the call whether or not he's
telling the truth and whether or not to
let him in like we want that to be
happening all over the country where
people have to explain their medical
history to like the guy at the door
no your medical history's private there
was a i saw a facebook post uh
this guy
he's like a a
studio recorder musician whatever and he
was like this should be obvious to
everybody about but i will not work with
anybody who is not vaccinated and all
the comments are people cheering
saying i won't service businesses that
don't have vaccine passports anymore
like it's the mandatory vaccine thing is
really taking off and i responded just
with i was like what if you know even
even people who have medical conditions
that are like
advised against or have risk factors
where they they're concerned about
getting it and he was like well i mean
obviously obviously
not in that circumstance but he says i
don't think it would be a good idea to
put him in a recording booth for eight
hours and i'm like
all right you know maybe that's a good
idea i mean obviously someone's having
an underlying health condition that you
know can cause them how the facts take
that stuff seriously but what was
worrying to me about that post was the
zealotry yeah so they talk about vaccine
hesitancy and i think regular people are
hesitant for medic or medications for a
lot of reasons you see the opioid crisis
what were they saying in the 90s it
wasn't that addictive or something so
people are are worried and they want to
get a trusted health professional to be
like here's my recommendation for you
and so now you have the opposite of that
you have vaccine zealotry where people
are just like shut up and get it don't
talk to your doctor and i'm like that's
crazy no talk to your doctor
but people are actually saying that so
when i tweeted stop listening to
celebrities call your medical
professional i got a bunch of people on
the left quote tweeting me saying you're
scaring people for no reason and
actually people say so what they're
gonna say go get it i'm like then what's
the problem right why are you mad that
i'm telling people to seek proper
medical advice
that creeps me out
i think you're right on if okay if for
instance they were like one percent of
the people in this age range have an
adverse reaction that doesn't mean that
you have a if you're in that danger age
have a one percent chance it means that
of all those people one percent of them
had adverse reaction but those people
might have had a specific issue
that isn't it's not random it's not it's
not randomly affecting like there's
specific reasons why people have
reactions so you have to go to a doctor
and examine yourself before you start
injecting yourself i mean it's you don't
have to but you really really should i
don't i don't like to taking uh i think
acetaminophen is edit yeah like this
right here it's really bad for a regular
painkiller yeah i have bad reactions to
it
and it's like it's breakers it's like
over-the-counter blood brain barriers
ibuprofen totally fine like i you know i
get a headache there i think i have a
proof and i feel great um acetaminophen
no i i i took it one time i got really
it gave me a really bad adverse reaction
like headache migraine and i'm like i
don't want to take the stuff anymore now
imagine if everybody said it's over the
counter it's safe everyone you can just
take it i'd be like dude
talk to your doctor they used to sell
cocaine over the counter
those are the days right didn't they say
asbestos was safe or something i think
heroin wasn't there heroin they still
sell cigarettes
did they really they still have those
ads where it was like nine out of ten
doctors right
mountain cigarettes are right for you
somebody just posted like a ad from the
olympics like the chosen cigarettes of
olympians oh my gosh
yeah things were crazy back in the day
man i was watching old times i was
watching like old sports and like old
olympics videos and like the skill level
was so dramatically lower yeah they
really didn't care about their clothing
and like the food they ate you know yeah
bayer used to sell heroin to children
have you ever seen that look at a bear
heroin image
it's the image of the old bottle hmm
interesting
baby now they just call it you know oh
they call it like oxycodone exactly
basically the same thing i don't know
what's the difference it's this new
stuff that's freaking me out that uh
that george floyd had and it's just
fentanyl
not that they're they're not prescribing
that stuff are they is that medical
things yeah
are they particularly they are sometimes
they prescribe fentanyl
i believe that it's relatively rare but
it's a pain controller and yes 100
people i was watching stargate thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you